wie sie wissen traditionell eher eine
notorische nörgler sendung aber ich
finde sobald etwas besser läuft muss man
das auch mal würdigen an dieser stelle
die impf geschwindigkeit in deutschland
zieht an und wie meine damen und herren
und wie am mittwoch über eine million an
einem tag rekord wenn wir in dem tempo
weiter machen dann sind das kann das mal
jemand hochrechnen
aber schauen sie mir wir haben jetzt
jeden vierten deutschen geimpft dieser
woche wird es noch jeder fünfte werden
genau und jeder sechste
gesundheitsminister hatte zu früh
abgewählt grünes image tempo also und
dann gab es am montag auch noch eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ohne zoff
wirklich es war total harmonisch und das
in dieser legendären runde wo
normalerweise alle durcheinander
schreien die hälfte beleidigt ist und
mindestens einer heult beim thema impfen
aber sind sich merkel und die
ministerpräsidenten ungewohnt einig für
eine gute konstruktive diskussion für
die ich mich sehr bedanken beschlossen
hat die runde nichts weil mir nichts
beschlossen haben war es auch etwas
leichter
das würde erklären wobei zum thema
rechte von geimpften hat die runde
immerhin ein meinungsbild erstellt und
ein eckpunktepapier besprochen was gibt
es da zu besprechen
erst hab natürlich haben geimpfte und
genesene mindestens die gleichen rechte
wie negativ getestet was denn sonst
dieses auf zeit spielen ist eine rein
politische entscheidung natürlich die
haben angst vor der vor der zwei klassen
gesellschaft vor dem großen impfen hyde
in einer welt in der doppelt geimpfte
alte im biergarten krass abfeiern
während der ungeimpfte durstig und
jugend über den zaun guckt weil in drei
minuten die ausgangssperre anfängt und
ich wäre hier bewusst dass biergarten
beispiel den achten sie mal darauf
inzwischen verspricht man uns bürger
nicht mal mehr mallorca ist sondern nur
noch biergarten dass wir eine chance
haben im sommer vielleicht einmal wieder
in einen biergarten zu sitzen diesem
sommer sitzen wir auch irgendwann mal im
biergarten irgendwie im sommer ist die
chance ziemlich hoch dass wir da auch
auf bierbänken sitzen können dass wir im
sommer auch mal wieder im biergarten
sitzen können spätestens da wusste ich
gar nicht dass er so eine party nudel
ist demnächst prophezeie ich werden wird
vor gericht klagen und argumentieren ich
bin geimpft mein personal ist geimpft
und ich möchte jetzt verdammt nochmal
geimpfte gäste empfangen
mit recht auch die gastronomie braucht
endlich mal irgendeine perspektive und
ganz ernsthaft auf wen oder was soll man
hier bitte gerade neidisch sein luxus
früher war das die jahre der ferrari die
frau mit dem gebauten hupen heute ist
luxus was völlig anderes luxus ist beim
friseur nicht erst mit dem teststäbchen
im kleineren rumpeln wie so looser
sondern direkt dran kommen weil man
geimpft ist zeigt den schoß dass der bar
bosch und zwei dosen intus hatte
das alles bei stabiles live auf der
doppelt geimpfte wahre luxus ist wenn
man gar keinen friseur braucht im mobile
in sozial schwachen viertel schicken wo
viel mehr leute krank werden wegen
wohnverhältnissen und wegen wenig home
office das wäre ein schritt zu mehr
gerechtigkeit das werden die
diskussionen die wir führen müssen und
im juni bemühen sich dann alle
ungeimpften gleichzeitig um ihren termin
das wird auch interessant wie läuft es
aktuell
wir haben momentan die priorisierung
gruppe 3 geöffnet das bedeutet über 60
jährige
das bedeutet asthmakranke krebskranke
aber auch steuerberater und
wirtschaftsprüfer steuerberater
warum nicht ein radfahrer pyrmont
kirchen tester oder querdenker und wieso
ernsthafte frage dauert es jetzt schon
wieder wochen bis der digitale impfpass
da ist angeblich wegen datenschutz
der komische gelbe lampen kann es ja
wohl auf dauer nicht sein da sind wir
uns einig vor allem weil der total
leicht zu fälschen ist zumindest
erfahrene kriminelle haben da wohl wenig
probleme so ein teil zu faken einfach
mit einem guten kartoffel stempel fertig
ist der impfpass mir hat auch schon
einen gemalt also digitaler impfpass
muss jetzt ganz schnell her und bitte
das ist wichtig bitte schluss mit der
blöden impf bürokratie es kann doch
nicht sein
acht bis zehn formulare pro erst und
zwei tim cook
was für eine zeit und wald verschwendung
wie unter kaiser will werden wir mitten
im digitalzeitalter noch gigantische
aktenberge aufgetürmt keiner ließ das
jemals alle fans bescheuert aber stoppen
kann man es auch nicht warum auch immer
von unseren impf hotlines mal ganz zu
schweigen
die ansage der rheinland-pfälzischen
corona hotline macht kathrin greifvogel
richtig sauer
die fdlr punkte seniorengerechter geht
es beim besten willen nicht ansonsten
haben wissen sie viele regionen in
deutschland jetzt eine woche
ausgangssperre hinter sich
ausgangssperre hätten wir uns samt
bundes notbremse ersparen können wenn
wir schon anfang des jahres einmal kurz
hart gebremst hätten
am ende wird wahrscheinlich karlsruhe
entscheiden ob die ganze ausgangssperre
verfassungskonform ist
logik brüche enthält sie in jedem fall
und mir persönlich weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht mir persönlich tun die
menschen leid die das alles
kontrollieren soll
[Musik]
liebe leute wir vom ordnungsamt sind die
letzte bastion jene pandemie die wächter
der ausgangssperre aber da gibt's zum
wagnis die ihr drauf haben müsst so der
versorgung von haustieren ist er rund um
die uhr erlaubt die kleinen wurst
maschinen die muss ja auch mal raus aber
ist dass da überhaupt der kelter dieser
person so gnädig sste dann rufen sie mal
bitte ihren hund habe ich doch gewusst
ob düsseldorf das gibt dem muskel
übrigens auch für den mann reden und
gegen geld geliehen hat völlig neuer
beruf und zuhälter ja und wer weiß wer
da noch alles mit drin steckt passe
davon gewusst freundlichen seite
[Musik]
spox ihre ist bis mitternacht erlaubt
aber alleine
hallo kommen sie mal her ordnungsamt 12
einer muss nach hause aber pronto ist
natürlich blöd die frau muss jetzt ohne
ihren mann weiter laufen in diesem
zwielichtigen viertel
hallöchen junge frau so ganz allein
unterwegs ausgangssperre
da kommt es vor allem auf
fingerspitzengefühl an das gespür für
den einzelfall auch war mensch sei das
hier zb absolut vorbildlich alleine
draußen für sportliche betätigung der
ist ob sport oder ordnungsamt düsseldorf
wir haben uns den quatsch nicht
ausgedacht so aufnahme hallo
dies ist die automatische and cut von
oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher